welcome to this video playing
international master Shannon blob on
chanandler bong mom from Sweden under
sawsan yeah yeah someone recently wrote
in one of the comments that they are
about 3,000 international masters in the
world so how to know the more but they
new names keep popping up in those
profiles okay playing the fitted oh yeah
always had somewhat somewhat soft spot
for this opening I always liked if black
manages to do that like to get this a 6b
five set up plate you know maybe I'm I'm
managing then be 50 s wow wow really
hmm okay yeah this is not so much
because i fear that g5s is a problem i
just want to increase the dark square
control yep attending nigeria if
possible I don't have to stand that or
what white is doing reroute in the
bishop from a good post on c4 to a
bedpost on g2 and in the process killing
over all the dark squares is so a bit
strange to to say the least okay Bishop
takes mm yeah pawn takes also not bad
blocking okay but Jung well I could have
thought about that it's not exactly
difficult that was you but it's not like
he didn't he didn't tell me as his
intentions and pretty obvious okay yeah
this is not too attractive but what else
okay well I'm not in trouble yeah well
then now I'm not in trouble at all the
d5 is just okay it's just completely
strange I mean why not open up the
default to have some play now Black is
just an excellent shape night fhg six
and white has no play at all maybe you
smoked a couple of bombs too many not
sure okay just joking my d5 this is
really a strange move whereas White's
play now
okay running right into my dead phone
yeah the only idea White's has left is
before you really should should play
that maybe not exactly now that the only
idea left okay should probably put yeah
it needs to be really rooted anyway
won't be seven this is really a useless
piece the only problem from blacks point
of view is that the position is really
very closed and this might might be an
issue but it's all noise that is playing
all those strange moves but if it's a
completely closed its are too hard to
win anyway should I play a b5 at some
point maybe I should prepare that it's
hard to do something under the King side
only
an ideas night h4 then g 6 + f5 nice
maybe maybe playing for f4f vdf form ok
I can play Queen g5 oh come on let's do
that just if I after the Queen traitor
black can play this on for ages ok it's
not trading Queens I don't mind that
h5 is serve as an idea now King ya know
I can just go here or not yeah okay it's
it's a good move
intending h5
okay I'll go h5 now what exactly is the
reply we cannot go queen g3l c2 is
hanging and I probably animal maybe you
must do that okay okay well 11 line that
this winning is enough you should we
should take JV also wins but this is
quite okay Fisher the three coming and
well corner three is what II what you
probably must do
and then I can okay now this is made
checkmate yeah this was a strange
incoming challenge nope I'm not playing
a rematch in five minute or in the the
regular blitz blitz game yeah this was
was a bit strange played in three
surprised by many moves we are here d 5
is the normal move but they're okay not
not necessary to do that he can you can
play that but the combination of bishop
f 1 and G flawless really strange didn't
expect that at all LH six Bishop g2
night h7 is all very very normal yeah we
have our pawn takes is probably better
but this it's not it's not a mistake not
a mistake here and see five but now d 5
is just a just a super strange move why
not taking here wherever I mean here you
at least have some some play we've got a
knife that you can put on d5 and maybe
some stuff going on on the default and
d5 is just giving me a completely
completely easy game going for them for
the week squares okay it's fairly
resilient does this a scam but like
black is just in good shape here also
night H for us what's good yeah maybe
you should exchange him but keeping the
Queen's on didn't didn't really help ya
here H Shrivers is also good but I think
this is also also probably winning yeah
minus minus two points something and
it's sir and it's only going up this
evaluation for black
yeah defy this is really leading to a
completely one-sided game where white
needs to be very very cautious to not
get blown away immediately which which
happened in the game all right thanks
for watching